thanks for for uh staying for the
final talk uh so i'm jacob nordstrom
the university of copenhagen london
university and i'm going to talk about
pseudo boolean solving
as something sitting right in between
set solving and integer linear
programming
um so so what is pseudo boolean solving
maybe the first question you know apart
from being a cool name
well as a theoretician i would call
this is just a function over the boolean
hypercube
and they have they're well studied
in operations research in inter-linear
programming
so we are going to be interested in um
when these pseudo-boolean functions are
linear functions
and that is enough to express a lot of
if you think of your
favorite np-complete problems then
chances are actually that it can be
expressed in linear pseudo-boolean form
and i should say right away that
what you'll get now is like a condensed
version of
um mostly a condensed version of what i
did during the summer's boot camp
so um you can view this as a teaser for
going to
that tutorial and listening to more of
the details there
but i'll uh i'll add some new twists i
guess especially towards the end
just to convince you that you should
stay um
anyway so why why do we want to do sudo
boolean
constraints so one reason is that it's a
much richer format than the cnf
format that sat solvers use i mean just
to say
out of six variables you want to say
that three are true that's just
one cardinality constraint uh as
you know opposed to this mouthful of
clauses where it's even hard to see that
i didn't do a
you know a bug somewhere i think in
earlier versions of these slides i even
had bugs
and i didn't even see them and in
addition once you move over to pseudo
boolean constraints it turns out that
you actually have stronger methods of
reasoning than the resolution method
that underlies cdco
um and but but the bonus is that you're
still close enough to set to look at all
the cool ideas that have
uh appeared in stat solving and you
could try to port them
to the pseudo boolean setting plus since
you
have a zero one interior linear program
and there are lots of interesting ideas
in in the mixed integer linear
programming community you can try to
to take ideas from there as well
okay so so just to make clear we're on
the same page
so suitable and constraints then will be
linear constraints
uh for the rest of this talk where uh i
have integer coefficients
uh an integer constant term uh literals
that's just variables or negated
variables
um that take values true or false
so one or zero um and and in general
like in a suitable constraint you could
have any way of comparing them but we
will
focus on it won't be too important for
the talk but it's like
kind of nice when you describe the how
you reason with sudo boolean constraints
and when you implement algorithms to use
what's called normalized form
where all of these coefficients and the
constant term they're non-negative
integers
and the reason that you can do this
without loss of generality is that if
you have a negative coefficient
for x i you just switch to not x i
instead and in this normalized
setting the the constant term is
is known as the degree or the degree of
falsity
okay so just to make sure again
continue our discussion to make sure
we're on the same page
so if you have a clauses in cnf
those are just special cases of
pseudo-boolean constraints because you
just sum up the literals and want at
least one of them to be true
and then we saw that cardinality
constraints is an example of a more
general class of constraints
and then you can go wild and have
arbitrary
coefficients like this constraint
which is like a general pseudo-boolean
constraint and another thing that is
nice with sudo boolean constraints is
that you can express a lot of things
staying inside this formalism for
instance sometimes it's useful to have
a variable encode the truth value of a
constraint say that i want
z to be true precisely when this
constraint holds
so the nice thing is that this also i
can write as a pair
of pseudo boolean constraints and i
won't go too much into the details but
you can see that
just the first line is the easiest one
to see here that
this says that if z is true this forces
indeed forces this constraint to be true
and then if you look at the second line
and you think a bit more then you
realize that
uh z false will actually force this
constraint to be false
so pseudo boolean constraints are
expressive
and nice to work with and what
so the input that we have are then
pseudo-boolean formulas just
conjunctions of such constraints
and then we have two problems that i
want to discuss with you
and one is just the satisfiability
problem but ported to sudo boolean
to a pseudo boolean setting so this is
pseudo boolean solving you
get a collection of pseudo boolean
constraints
and you want to know whether they are
satisfiable or whether they're feasible
but another bonus with
going to pseudo boolean form is that
you can have you can express
optimization problems in a in a nice and
natural way
so you can also have some linear
combination of literals weighted by some
coefficients wi
and that you want to minimize say
without loss of generality
so then the problem becomes that you
want to find
a satisfying assignment to f and among
all such assignments you want to
minimize
the objective so that's that's the
the setting that's the problem that we
want to understand and
so what i'm going to tell you a little
bit about is
how you can do this by using so-called
pseudo-boolean solvers
and i'll then also
try to discuss how you can borrow ideas
from the sat side in particular from max
sat solving and also from mixed integer
linear programming
and this is again going to be like more
of a
a brief overview talk or a sales pitch
that i think this is something that
might be interesting to look more into
and so i'll
try to give you some pointers and there
are some um
some literature references on the slides
and they are all available at the end of
the slides which i
assume might be somewhere on the simon's
webpage later or if not then they will
be on my webpages
okay so what do you do if you get a
pseudo-boolean formula
well one thing that you can do since you
know and love conflict-driven
close-running solvers you just rewrite
your pseudo-boolean constraints
to conjunctive normal form and run your
favorite set solver
this is one thing you can do
another approach which is the one that
i've been working more on is
so in one sense you're like you want to
stay with conflict driven
close learning but you port your input
from sudo boolean to cnf so i want to go
in the other direction mostly i want to
stay with the pseudo boolean format and
i want to port
cdcl to a sudo boolean setting
and in particular i think there are two
solvers that are being actively
developed that i know of that are
are following this approach and this is
sat4j by the team in
in lance france and then rounding set
which is being developed by our group
um so okay how do you do it
what how does cdcl-based suitable
installing work
well it it's it's being used because it
turns out that it's uh
often a very competitive approach and
you know sadly i have to say from the
point of view of so-called native
pseudo-boolean solving
the cdcl-based approaches sometimes just
beat the crap out of us
and it's interesting to understand why
and i don't fully
understand why so that's an interesting
research question but
you can i mean it can be noted that when
you
rewrite the pseudo boolean formula to
cnf then you're introducing extension
variables
and these extension variables they mean
interesting things
and they so they give you a lot of extra
power
um and that means that if you have a
disjunction over such
extension variables then actually that
encodes some kind of polytope if you
look at the original problem so it
in some sense that we don't really
understand it it gives you a way of
doing fairly powerful reasoning just
because the variables
mean things that you couldn't speak
about before in a pseudo-boolean solver
because there was no variable for this
thing however
in order for this to work you really
want your uh formula to be encoded in a
nice way so for instance if i'm evil
and i try to permute the variables and
the constraints so that they come in a
not so natural order
then it seems that the cdcl based
approaches take a huge hit in
performance
and also for some problems like say
if you're working on on pigeonal
principle formulas you just have the
basic fact that no encoding
into cnf can compensate for the fact
that cdcl-based reasoning
is exponentially weaker than
pseudo-boolean reasoning for such
formulas and this you can also see
sometimes um
so but but there are like i think a lot
of
interesting problems so like one
interesting problem is
uh when you're doing the rewriting how
do you
rewrite to cnf in the best possible way
there is a lot of research on this a lot
of different
encodings i don't think we really
understand
from a rigorous point of view which
encodings are good or bad
uh another interesting question is how
would you
i'd like to understand better how the cd
seal-based approaches
compare to the cutting beans cutting
planes based approaches that i'm going
to discuss briefly next
in particular they seem to be somewhat
complementary and it would be
nice to well on the one hand to
theoretically understand what's going on
for instance could we somehow pin down
how helpful these new auxiliary
variables are
this i don't understand and also um i
mean if
if the cdcl-based approach is sometimes
good and the
cutting planes based approach is
sometimes good then why don't we try to
build a solver
that somehow tries to do both and get
the best of both worlds
i think this would be a nice thing to do
um okay
so um so moving on to pseudo-boolean
conflict-driven search so this is now
when i want to keep
my input in sudo boolean form
but i want to
do like the conflict-driven search and
learning because i've seen how good that
is
in set solving so like do the same thing
as as in cdcl but using
cutting planes instead of the resolution
proof system
and operating on pseudo-boolean
constraints rather than
clauses so what do i mean by the same
thing
well we would have the same setup where
there is this cycle of
assigning deciding on variables and then
making obvious propagations so you have
a decision propagation cycle
and there's a natural way of
generalizing
what it means for a pseudo boolean
constraint to propagate
and right if if for suitable and
constraints will be violated unless i
set x to true then that means that this
pseudo boolean constraint propagates
to true so i do this
decision propagation cycle until i hit
the conflict which is a violated
constraint
and then what i want to do is i want to
look at all on my
all of my propagations that i've made
that led to this conflict i want to look
at these constraints
and then i want to do conflict analysis
and learn a new constraint
but this constraint is going to be um
pseudo boolean
and i'm going to have to use some other
form of reasoning
than a resolution to do it and
the reasoning that we're going to use is
cutting planes so cutting planes like
traditional cutting planes is this
so that we know that all literals are
non-negative
and then we know that we can take
positive linear combinations so c
a and c b are positive numbers here
and then you have this division rule
which just says that
and here i'm using that the constraint
is written in normalized form that all
of these coefficients are positive
then i can just divide by a c and round
up everywhere so this is like
how cutting planes is is presented in
the proof complexity literature
going back to cook at all but then if
you're doing solving
you also want to use the saturation rule
and maybe
saturation is easier to see by an
example also division by an example so
suppose
suppose i have this constraint x plus 2y
plus 4z
greater than or equal to 3 then if i
divide by 2
and round up everywhere then i get x
plus y
plus 2z greater or equal to so this is
what division does
what saturation does it says well i mean
if this constraint is satisfied
then having the coefficient four here is
clearly overdoing it
actually three is enough so if this
constraint x plus two y plus four z
greater
greater equal three holes then the same
constraint with three z instead
also holds both of these rules
importantly
are using that we know uh that the
variables
are are integers so this is like
the rest of the rules this is just uh
linear programming basically but here
you have the boolean rules
and it's nice to have boolean rules if
we're going to solve boolean problems
so but doing the same thing just
but just with pseudo boolean constraint
that's opening a can of worms and i
think this is like
an area where we could really use more
uh
uh research um one the first annoying
problem is that if you take this fancy
pseudo
solver but you feed it a cnf formula in
the proper sudo boolean encoding
then everything just collapses to cdcl
but with very very expensive data
structures and this is a major weakness
as i see it
something that has been proposed is to
try to rewrite
your input and see if it could be
rewritten to for instance cardinality
constraints in a better way
and this has been implemented but it's
not actually
yet good enough to be used in practice
um so so you really so one thing if you
if you're going to use a pseudo boolean
solver you have to pay attention to your
encoding
like don't use the cnf encoding if your
problem is really a cnf problem
then you probably shouldn't be using a
sudo boolean solver
another problem is that even if you get
a nice encoding
we do have examples of where
you have zero one integer linear
programs where even the linear
relaxation
is infeasible so you don't need any
boolean reasoning to decide that there
is no solution i mean just just
just linear programming is enough and
this should be very easy for cutting
planes reasoning and still
solvers take forever this is another
very annoying
fact a third uh area of possible
improvement
is that pre-processing is something that
is very important in set solving it's
also
being used in inter linear programming
but so far
the pseudo boolean solvers don't really
have it
and this is probably another source of
of possible improvement
um so these are like i guess saying that
there i believe there is quite a
bit of low hanging fruit where you can
take um
insights from either sat solving or
interlinear programming and if you just
implement it then probably pseudo
boolean solvers would become much better
[Music]
another interesting uh question is that
it turns out that when you're doing this
conflict analysis on pseudo-boolean
constraints then
many degrees of freedom arise and again
going into details would be
take a lot of time so i have to refer
you to the tutorial but there are a lot
of like
scenarios that a lot of choices that you
just didn't have before
in cdcl but with suitable and
constraints you do for instance
um i mean in in cdcl you're going to do
your conflict analysis with
resolution period but in a
pseudo-boolean setting you could use
maybe division maybe saturation maybe
combining them maybe doing something
else
you can massage your pseudo-boolean
constraints and simplify them in
different ways
when you finally decide to learn a
constraint it can be
asserting at several different levels so
how far should you back jump
another thing is since the coefficients
are integers
what kind of precision do you want do
you want to stay in fixed position
and round when you're overflowing or do
you want to be in arbitrary precision
and just as such a basic question of
what is a good learned constraint what
is a strong constraint
for a clause this is in sometimes
obvious
the fewer literals you have in a clause
the stronger it is
but for a pseudo boolean constraint
there
it's like at least two dimensional on
the one hand you have how many variables
it involves
but the question is also how the
coefficients
relate to the degree of falsity and so
you could
be in a scenario where you can learn
several incomparable constraints and we
don't
have a good sense of which one is the
best one and there are also
interesting theoretical questions about
understanding
different subsystem of cutting planes
for instance how does
cunning planes with division compare to
the canning planes using saturation
lots of room for for improving our
understanding there
uh but still i mean th this these
solvers do work well uh in the sense
that there are a lot of
uh if you have a decision problem and if
it's natural
to encode in pseudo-boolean form
then we do have lots of examples where
pseudo-boolean solvers are clearly
stronger than cdcl solvers
not not just pigeonal principle formulas
would be like the the obvious toy
example but also lots of other
examples going
further from decision problems to
optimization problems
we can borrow ideas from max
sat so one obvious way to do
optimization is just linear search
so you run your solver and you want to
minimize this objective function say
sum of of w-i-l-i for later sli
just run the solver find a solution and
then you add a constraint saying now i
want something better i want something
smaller than what you found
and run the solver again and keep going
until
the formula is unsatisfiable at which
point
you know you found an optimal solution
this
is like simple but it works reasonably
well in particular
you can often get a decent solution
quickly which might be interesting
in applied scenarios where you actually
not
interested in solving to optimality but
maybe you have limited time and you want
some decent solution
quickly and linear search can be good
but of course the downside is that you
don't
know how good your solution is because
you have no idea of of what the matching
lower bound might be
um another interesting idea also from
uh maxat is like
the dual is to do core guided search so
now you say okay
here's my objective let's be optimistic
the best possible scenario here would be
that it's possible to set all literals
to zero
that would give the minimum zero i'm
assuming again here that all the w i's
are non-negative so i'll just assume
this i'll run my solver with assumptions
so pre-made decisions
for setting the whole objective function
to zero and now
one of two things can happen either this
works out and then i've clearly found
the
optimal solution or it doesn't and then
i learn
the reason why that you know maybe some
collection of
of these literals at least a of them
have to be true okay
and then i can use this to
update my estimate of what the best
possible solution is
and i can actually also rewrite the
objective function by introducing new
variables
and run from the top again and
keep going until i find an optimal
solution which will be when
my when in my rewritten objective
function i can set everything to zero
uh then i know i have the optimal value
and then i have sort of computed
uh how much i changed my objective
during this rewriting
so this means that i work with lower
bounds and it can
turns out that it can be helpful to get
good lower bounds because this help
cuts this helps to cut off the search
space you know
it cuts off places where there's no
reason to go
the downside is obviously that you don't
find a solution until
you have the optimal solution and you
don't know for that reason you don't
know how good your lower bound is
so then you know what if we try to
combine linear search
and um core guided search wouldn't that
be nice and it turns out that yes it
would be
and the nice thing compared to maxsite
is that this is much much cleaner and
simpler to do
in a pseudo boolean setting so this is
something that we did
and i had in in triple ai just a
few weeks ago um
so here for comparison here are our two
good um pseudo boolean solvers sat4j
and then the cdcl based solver naps and
here are different versions
different combinations of pseudo boolean
solving with core guided search and
linear search interleaved and
if you compare like these rows and the
rules down here you can see that there
are overall like significant
improvements sadly however we're not
beating the academic mip solver skip
i'll get back to that
in a in a minute
um so
what's up with with uh map solvers so
map solvers actually solve
a much more general problem
so then you have some of the variables
will be integral
and not necessarily boolean and other
variables will be real valued
except as as a special case if you don't
have any real valued variables then you
have an integer linear program and in an
if in addition all of these variables
are bounded between zero and one
then you have a zero one integer linear
program which is just another name for
the
for the pseudo boolean formulas that we
started with um
and if you want to do pseudo boolean
solving then you just do
you give a vacuous objective function
but it turns out that mip solvers are
not so good for decision problems they
somehow
they really use the objective function
heavily
to guide the search so we we
actually have it's not so hard to find
decision problems where pseudo-boolean
solders will beat mip solvers but
finding
optimization problems where sudo boolean
solvers are better that is not so easy
so what mips always do is again they
have
as is already said they have
pre-processing which is important
and then they work by
not trying to find boolean solutions but
instead they relax
the problem solve linear programming
linear programming relaxations and then
try to
use that to um
store information about how good or bad
the solution can be and then they use
something that's called branch and bound
and they also derive new
integer linear inequalities that rule
out
solutions to the relaxation that are not
integral
and this is something that's called
branch and cut
and then you combine this with lots and
lots of heuristics
okay so if you compare to pseudo boolean
solvers
pseudo boolean solvers have really good
conflict analysis
um but as i already mentioned they
are not great even on some problems
where the lp relaxation is infeasible
they'll still run forever
this is a scenario where mip solders
would terminate immediately because they
solve
just in the very first root node they
solve the lp relaxation they see that
it's infeasible they terminate
immediately
okay so mixed integer linear programming
solvers have
powerful search they use the lp
relaxations they have lots of different
ways of adding constraints
but when you show infeasibility then
they basically just backtrack
so this suggests that why don't we try
to get the best of both worlds we
use the powerful search of mip and then
the sophisticated conflict analysis of
pseudo-boolean solvers
okay this sounds great it's easier said
than done
but we have done this
uh so what we did we took our solar
rounding sat and
integrated it with the lp solver
suplex from this mib solver skip
and then you can add different belts and
whistles you can also take these
gomorrah cuts that are computed to rule
out lp relaxation solutions
you can also ask the pseudo boolean
solver to share
the constraints that it learns during
conflict analysis to send them to the lp
solver
and when we run this on knapsack
problems then we see that all of these
techniques
so here is like the base rounding sat
and all of these techniques
really makes the solver significantly
better although we're still not beating
skip but
in fairness it should be said also that
map solvers have a lot of special
purpose methods
to detect and solve knapsack constraints
with for instance dynamic programming
and we don't do that we're just running
our standard conflict driven search here
let's compare to some other benchmarks
so if we look at the pseudo-boolean
competition benchmarks
decision and optimization instances and
some miplib
instances again decision and
optimization problems then
um well i guess we don't get the
performance that we were
hoping for uh but at least the hybrid
solver is always
second best so like if you had to pick
one solver then you shouldn't pick the
pseudo boolean solver you shouldn't pick
the mixed
mip solver you should pick our hybrid
because it's always like you know
reasonably good although it would have
been nicer if it i mean clearly
you could also make the argument that if
you care about optimization then still
it seems like mip solvers are winning
um so but
this is i think it's it's it's um
before we conclude from this that that
pseudo boolean solvers
are hopeless it should be noted that
there's been like
tons and tons of manures in invested in
uh coding up fine-tuning mip solvers
there are
huge industrial solvers and
and the pseudo boolean solving is really
in comparison
not at all that well explored so i would
argue that the fact that you can get
this good results with so limited effort
to me this shows that i think sudo
boolean source is something we should
look more deeply into and there are lots
of of interesting
problems one could look at how to
interact between the
the linear programming solver and the pb
solver
how to make the pseudo boolean solver
use information from the lp relaxations
for instance that we don't do
i already mentioned that why don't we
use pre-processing
in particular we could take the mip
pre-solving techniques that work in a
pseudo-boolean setting and tag them on
so this is you have to be a little bit
careful because some mips solving
techniques will change
zero one integer linear programming
problems into other types of problems
but it should be possible to deal with
this
another interesting fact is that that
you have a wide like a rich library of
different cut rules that you could in
principle plug into suitable and
conflict analysis and see
if something better pops out this is
something that i really would like to do
and now this is like ends where i was in
my tutorial and after the tutorial
during the boot camp i basically got
questions saying that nice but you know
why would any sane person actually do
sudo boolean solving
so then i realized that i was maybe
underselling a little bit so i want
you know for fairness sake i want to
balance the picture and say that there
are in fact
applications where already
pseudo-boolean solvers are outperforming
even commercial mip solvers
you just take you know a standard pseudo
boolean solver off the shelf
and for instance for problems like
arithmetic circuit verification it turns
out that
pseudo boolean solders are state of the
art
some people in glasgow
matching doing some kind of matching
problems for children with adoptive
families apparently
they take the same problems and they run
our solver instead it's
order of magnitude better than the mip
solvers they used
another nice application area which
might be interesting for people who work
on this
neural networks in particular binarized
neural networks
the issue with those is you get a lot of
refined constraints for the activation
functions
and those are really they're really
killing mip solvers because
when you relax them they get very
uninformative
but pseudo boolean solvers deal really
nicely with this refit constraint so
again we see like
just off-the-shelf order magnitude
performance and improvement compared to
mid
okay so this concludes my sales pitch
so i guess what i wanted to say is
pseudo boolean optimization
is it's a it's an expressive and
powerful framework but it's
close enough to sat that you can use all
your favorite ideas from sat
you can use ideas from mac sat in some
sense you know it can be argued that max
sat
and pseudo boolean optimization are just
two different ways of describing the
same problem
i believe that we have not we're very
far from
exploiting the full power of cutting
planes which is
exponentially stronger than what the
reasoning that we're using on the sat
side
and i also do believe that we could use
a lot of the insights from the mixed
integer linear programming
um literature um
and there are certainly uh i mean we're
not
where we would like to be in terms of
performance because of course we would
like to beat
the competition all of them including
the mip solders and we don't there are a
lot of
interesting challenges for how to design
the algorithms also efficient
implementation is a huge
challenge like a question like uh how to
propagate
pseudo-boolean constraints is much more
costly than propagating clauses
and this is really slowing down solvers
also different reasoning methods
we just don't understand them as well as
we understand the resolution proof
system underlying cdcl
but we already know that there are
applications where off-the-shelf
cutting planes based solvers are beating
the competition so
if you're looking at for instance you
know binarized neural networks or
something maybe
you should take a look at a
pseudo-boolean solver and see if it can
do some anything for you
so that's it
thank you jacob
so i'll take the first question so
for resolution is a is a perfect fit for
for a for cdcl because we know that if
you have a set of clauses
and you want to eliminate a variable
then you need to use
what you do is exactly resolution so
resolution
is equivalent to quantify quantified
elimination variable elimination
what is the corresponding statement if i
have a bunch of pseudo
pseudo boolean constraints i want to do
variable elimination
do we have the same kind of a theorem
that would give us the same result that
we have an algorithm it has given us an
algorithm to eliminate variables
cutting planes saturations division and
saturation
i'm not sure i mean
my question clear
i have a set of suitable constraints and
i want to eliminate the variable
and get the exist x such that
a set of wooden suitable unconscious i
want can i represent it for example by
sort of
suitable and constraints even is the
projection
through the bullet i suppose so but
i've never seen the theorem they would
state what exactly is the projection
operation
i mean it i i think the answer is yes
but i'm not sure it's very interesting
like i mean it's definitely a complete
method right so you can you can
like eliminate in some sense i think you
could do
like the analog of davis putnam
resolution
but i haven't thought about it in that
way and i don't know
i i i'm afraid i might not have a good
answer i mean maybe someone from the
audience would have a good answer
so this is a theoretical result because
it's important because it tells us that
the right thing you need to do when you
have a conflict
is to generate the conflict clause
and it is the resolution so it gives us
also a tight connection
between what cdcl does and you know we
have a theorem that connects
directly to both complexity okay we said
it generates
basically uh if you have cdcl plus three
star that gives you
uh it fails the resolution proof is
going to be of linear
of size linear or same size essentially
as a search tree
do we have the same kind of theoretical
uh foundations here
to some extent yes to some extent i mean
it's definitely the case that if you
look at what the sudobuna solars are
doing
they will spit out cutting planes proofs
in exactly the same way
as a cdcl solver produces a resolution
proof
and this is a complete method so one big
difference
is that for for cdcl we have the
theoretical result
saying that assuming that your
heuristics are somehow magically optimal
then conflict-driven close learning with
restarts
is never more than polynomially worse
than resolution
so cdcl searches efficiently for
resolution proofs
this is false in a pseudo-boolean
setting
we are not searching efficiently for
coming planes proofs
that's important thank you
other questions are there any questions
on the charts
let me check the chat
yeah i have one yeah um so so this
uh mip you see they did it it looks to
me like uh look ahead right like the
thing what marvin was explaining
you spend lots of time in every search
note and the of course your pb server
does the opposite it's more like city
sales so the obvious question is of
course like just do what we did right
with this cube and conquer but for
pb no but and related to that are there
incremental pb servers because this is
something where
we need to for this cube and conquer
actually
um you mean increment um
[Music]
i think that the the answer is that all
that
needs to be done in that setting could
be done but maybe it isn't as well
developed in the sense of having a
standard library or api for how to do
this and this is probably something that
we should do
um but yeah i think it's interesting to
note
like the parallels with marine stock i
was as i was listening to it
it's it's very similar in philosophy
but it's slightly different
in the so so one thing that i mean also
mip solvers would have this kind of
thing where they
probe variables and collect statistics i
think they call this strong branching
except that they actually consider this
to be too expensive i think so they do
this
strong branching at the start but then
when you've been running for a while
they collect statistics of how how this
branching worked out
and based on this they
make estimates of what's going to happen
in the future and this is something that
they call pseudocosts
so this is like an interesting question
whether you would do look ahead solving
and not
not do full probing but sort of do
intelligent guesses based on how things
have been performing previously that
would be
porting myth techniques into look ahead
if but i don't know how
expensive the look ahead step is and
then another thing that
is nice i mean i think there's a lot of
questions to explore
at the interface of pseudo boolean
solving and mip solving but the fact
that you can
when you find the solution but it's
like you relax the problem you find a
rational solution that you can add a new
cut
which is a sound constraint
that cuts away this rational solution
and so
tightens your polytope this is important
and this we see that as i showed in some
of the experiments
this can really improve um this can
really improve performance another thing
that can improve performance is
when we're somewhere in the middle of
the search and we're asking the lp
solver so the pseudo bonus order cannot
see the contradiction
but the residual lp is already
infeasible
in that case a mip solver can help us by
seeing
a that it is infeasible and b by farkas
lemma it returns a conflict constraint
so that we can like
you know fast forward the conflict
analysis and this turns out to be these
constraints are apparently like super
useful
um yeah so but but it's an interesting
question
yeah i don't yeah experiments look like
you would import like a mip
technology into pb silver right but this
turns it around right so you would use a
tb a mid
approach and then one point switch to bb
that's what i'm asking
yeah that that's uh i i yeah that's
interesting
um i think uh
so one problem has been to explain how
pseudobulin conflict analysis
works and the fact that it is
exponentially more powerful
this is somehow a message that is hard
to get across
but i think it's slowly sinking in and
that
it's more like i think there are people
on the mip side that would like to do
sudo boolean conflict analysis
but the question is whether it will
happen because there's
you know i mean there's so many
interesting questions to pursue
but yeah that's definitely like taking
what we have done is is is like the the
mips the pb solver is clearly the master
and the lp solver is the slave you could
turn this relationship around and let
the conflict analysis be the slave
um yeah this is definitely something
that i'd like to do
miguel do you have a question
so this is this approach similar to sat
modulo integer linear arithmetic in the
smt setting yes and no
i think it's stronger in the sense
that since we're
operating on the linear constraint i
think in an smt setting you would be
restricted to deriving
facts that you can express in the
variables that you have
right you have variables that mean
certain things
and you can derive facts about those but
now when we're massaging our linear
constraints we'll generate tons and tons
of new linear constraints
so like in an smt setting this would
correspond to i guess
you know generating a lot of extension
variables
which i don't think the smt solvers do
so in that sense i think it's slightly
orthogonal
thomas do you have a question
if someone decides to encode a given
pseudo-boolean formula into cnf is there
any known worst case upper bounds
regarding space there are lots of
results on
on how to do this yeah i mean you can do
it efficiently
there are two parameters that you trade
off the encoding size and the
propagation strength
and this has i mean there's a this is a
research area
and in the tutorial i have like some
some references for this
but but there's still room for like the
theoretical results don't
perfectly match what people actually use
in practice and there's probably room
for improvement
um any last question
sibila asks regarding back jumping with
chronological backtracking similar to
chronological cdcl works
not jump to any asserting level
uh in some sense yes so we
we don't know in sudo boolean solvers
that we're back jumping to the right
level so in in some sense
all the extra hacks needed to make cdcl
work in a chronological setting in some
sense
i would argue they are most of them are
already there in a pseudo-boolean
setting because we already need to deal
with these problems
if that's an answer to the question
okay we got all the questions answered
thank you jacob i think
we had a great session on three
different approaches to
survey so i will close the session and
we didn't even lose power
some of them must have optimized the
power appropriately
so close the session we'll see your left
side all the speakers
and we'll see you all next week bye